rope he's lost the other debris and he's
lost the other flotation device slowly
but surely uh hopefully they'll be able
to make contact with this victim very
close here as a tense rescue continues
those uh Swift currents from the water
and now The Rescuer and the rescue e are
free and being hoisted up into an LA
City fire helicopter copter two I
believe it's like it was copter five
excuse me copter two is also working
this scene here positioned down river
just in case anything happens and
they're going to be in this helicopter
in short order and hopefully this victim
uh will be treated and uh in a little
warmer conditions in short order